was super into WCW NWO Revenge
let's go I gotta stop you tell me those
wasn't the best wrestling games of all
time come on come on they were the best
like WWE have no mercy I'll never forget
I had I probably was playing that game
for like two three months when I
realized you could throw people
backstage and then I was like and you
could like Stone Cold some people
through the pool table like it was yeah
it was oh my God
yes but he revenge and low-key revenge
is my favorite because the jump the jump
from world tour to Revenge was kind of
Bonkers if you really about it Revenge
was the template for everything moving
forward with the WWE games but that
Revenge oh man yeah we had so much fun
with that game
the intro sequence to that is so insane
yes it is and then it just like sticks
sting yeah yes it's just like beanie and
they're just like like rendering these
terrible these